c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soit il est bienvenu sur france 24 à la
une ce soir les trois heures de dialogue
entre les partis politiques et le
gouvernement de transition en guinée un
dialogue d'entamé grâce à la pression
exercée par les acteurs de l'opposition
une rencontre pour justement parler de
la transition en cours dans le pays nous
serons à conakry dans ce journal
l'onu qui tente de lancer un dialogue
entre les différentes parties au soudan
des discussions indirectes pour
commencer les tensions sont vives dans
le pays depuis le coup d'état du général
abdelfattah taiwan et les manifestations
contre le pouvoir militaire sont
violemment réprimées
les résultats des matches de la coupe
d'afrique des nations deux grands
favoris ont raté leur entrée dans la
compétition l'egypte pays le plus titré
de la can s'est inclinée face au nigeria
et l'algérie la tenante du titre a fait
match nul contre la sierra leone nous
serons en direct de yaoundé avec peut
noter rocher
c'est une première depuis le coup d'état
en guinée les partis politiques ont été
invités au dialogue avec le gouvernement
de transition le dialogue et qui a duré
trois heures a été à convoquer convoqué
grâce à la pression exercée par
l'opposition les explications de notre
correspondant à conakry mali diakité les
échanges ont essentiellement porté sur
la chronologie la durée de la transition
qui ne sont toujours pas connues pendant
plus de trois heures les acteurs
politiques qu'a tout de rôle se sont
plaints au ministre de l'administration
sur le manque de dialogue entre les
partis politiques et la junte au pouvoir
il souhaite discuter directement avec
les nouvelles autorités sur les
questions liées à la transition ces
acteurs politiques qui se sont récemment
réunis en une plateforme pour parler
d'une seule voix face à la junte pour
moi qu'un cadre de dialogue
créé et qu'on puisse se retrouver par
rapport aux questions susceptibles de
diviser pour prévenir les conflits comme
les mémos conad d'épouser un à paris la
possibilité de les défendre pour
confronter nos différents points de vue
afin de retenir quelque chose qui semble
être le plus consensuel au nom du
gouvernement le ministre de
l'administration a réitéré son
engagement à crier ce cadre de dialogue
avec toutes les forces vives du pays les
mémorandums que nous avons reçu leur la
concertation nous ont permis de la baule
achats de la tradition également ça
permet au cnrd de mettre en place un
gouvernement
100% civile est aujourd'hui à conduire
des actions du pays le gouvernement est
engagé pour le galop que c'est pourquoi
moi j'ai reçu mandat
d'ouvrir cette discussion à noter que le
président de la transition a annoncé
l'organisation des assises nationales au
cours du premier trimestre 2002 avec
tous les guinéens pour une transition
apaisée une transition dont la durée n'a
toujours pas déterminé
cette main tendue en guinée intervient
quelques jours après l annonce des
sanctions contre le mali par la cedeao
la junte militaire au pouvoir en guinée
a d'ailleurs apporté son soutien à
bamako les autorités maliennes qui ont
de leur côté appelé les maliens
manifesté vendredi contre ces sanctions
la situation politique au soudan
préoccupe l'onu son émissaire dans le
pays a annoncé le lancement de
discussions indirectes avec les parties
civiles et militaires soudanaises pour
tenter de mettre fin à la crise
déclenchée par le coup d'état du 25
octobre dernier les détails avec camille
nédélec
un dialogue pour tenter de résoudre la
crise au soudan l'onu espère pouvoir
négocier la paix entre les autorités
soudanaises et le mouvement pro
démocratique après le coup d'état
militaire d'octobre dernier la junte n'a
pas refusé les échanges mais n'a pas
encore accepté non plus et certaines
parties civiles ont déjà annoncé qu'elle
ne participerait pas
pour la can à ce moment là bas où les
honneurs
du match
lundi les ambassadeurs de la suède et la
norvège ont visité l'hôpital de khartoum
en soutien au médecin car le 30 décembre
l'hôpital s'est transformé en scènes
d'horreur lorsque les forces de sécurité
ont lancé des bombes lacrymogènes à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital où des
manifestants blessés se faisait soigner
le ballon rase
brigade de table rase
al-hameli chez thomann l'air la rue à la
crise à la morgue où
le stade et la roma depuis le putsch les
manifestations sont régulières des
manifestations réprimées par les forces
de sécurité et des dizaines de personnes
sont mortes les autorités elles
contestent le prix mais les
manifestations
au burkina faso une enquête a été
ouverte et huit militaires ont été
arrêtés ils ont été accusés d'avoir
projeté de déstabiliser les institutions
les huit hommes sont interrogés le
parquet militaire affirme avoir été
informé du projet de déstabilisation des
institutions de la république par un
groupe de militaires par un membre de la
bande sur dénonciation
ce verdict en république démocratique du
congo la justice militaire a condamné
lundi deux policiers à la perpétuité ils
ont été jugés responsables de la mort de
rossi mukendi un militant pro démocratie
tue en février 2018 c'est la première
fois que des membres des forces de
l'ordre sont condamnés pour avoir
réprimé des manifestations sous l'ère
kabila la correspondance à kinshasa de
clément monroe rossi mukendi avait été
abattu par la police le 25 février 2018
au cours d'une manifestation pacifique
pour exiger le départ de l'ancien
président joseph kabila après un an de
procès deux policiers ont donc été
condamné ce lundi à la prison à
perpétuité
la commissaire supérieur adjointe karine
look et son est notamment reconnu
coupable de participation aux meurtres
et de violation des consignes ce jour là
en effet la police avait interdit le
port d'armes à feu à ses effectifs mais
c'est un autre policier le brigadier est
au kiss in combo qui est désigné comme
étant l'auteur du tir pour la famille de
rossi et mukendi ce verdict est un
immense soulagement mais elle juge
insuffisante la somme de 125 mille
dollars qui doit leur être versée comme
dommages et intérêts nous sommes
satisfaits dans l'aspect pénal et non
dans l'aspect civil et d'ailleurs je
nous avons fait une procuration à nos
avocats aujourd'hui pour déposer dans
les délais de la loi pour relever appel
dans les domaines dans l'aspect civil
afin que les juges d'appel puisse revoir
ces montants la vie humaine est sacrée
la vie ne pouvait pas quantifier la
vidéo ci à une somme je sais pas combien
mais il fallait quand même être humain
pensée ne serait ce qu'à l'avenir de ses
enfants les avocats des deux policiers
ont également annoncé vouloir faire
appel le brigadier affirme en effet que
c'est un autre policier qui avait ouvert
le feu le verdict a en tout cas était
saluée par plusieurs organisations de la
société civile pour human rights watch
il s'agit d'un message fort envoyé aux
forces de l'ordre lohan g qui estime je
cite que l' usage d'une force excessive
contre des manifestants pacifiques ne
doit pas rester impuni
en afrique du sud l'homme suspecté
d'être à l'origine de l'incendié qui a
ravagé le parlement a été entre autres
accusés de terrorisme le sans abri de 49
ans avait été arrêté dès le jour de
l'incendié alors qu'ils se trouvaient
dans l'enceinte du bâtiment il a été
inculpé trois jours plus tard lors d'une
brève comparution devant un tribunal du
cap depuis son arrestation de nombreuses
voix se sont élevées pour souligner
qu'il n'est qu'un bouc émissaire la
correspondance au cap de caroline dumay
sans délai m'a fait est apparu un peu
différent devant la justice
sud-africaine vêtu d'un costume noir il
n'avait plus l'air d'un sans abri mais
déjà des éléments importants de
l'enquète pers le suspect aurait été
diagnostiqué schizophrène paranoïaque il
faudrait au moins 30 jours
d'observations pour savoir s'il est en
pleine possession de ses facultés
mentales
rome 2 2
à l'extérieur de la cour bon fut
manifesté pour sa libération des
militants d' orange et 200 abris comme
vini sia qui dit bien connaître sans
délai quand elle l'a nourri plusieurs
fois écoutez là
il a un cap mental je ne pense pas qu'il
sera capable de penser à aller dans un
endroit hautement sécurisé forcé
l'entrée y mettre le feu non ce n'est
pas possible pour un dîner thévenot de
notting hill
les jours passent et les questions de
mort personne ne sait s'il incendie au
parlement du cap était finalement un
accident ou s'il était intentionnel et
s'ils étaient prémédités on se demande
encore pourquoi
direction la tunisie où l'émergence du
variant au micron inquiète les autorités
sanitaires qui se prépare à une
cinquième vague plus de 6 millions
tunisiens ont reçu leur dose mais le
pass vaccinale mis en place depuis le 22
décembre dernier rencontre beaucoup de
problèmes reportage de nos
correspondants lilia blaise est ridicule
sur l'avenue bourguiba samedi une
centaine de personnes réunies par la
coordination anti passe crient leur
opposition à l'obligation de se faire
vacciner mais aussi aux passes vaccinale
a présenté dans les lieux de travail les
espaces publics et les grandes surfaces
décembre
dubaï
dans les universités la rentrée a été
chaotique près de 70% des étudiants
boycotter les examens entre les grèves
estudiantines liées à la période de
révision et ceux qui n'avaient pas le
pass vaccinale les étudiants musulmans
seul vaccin
les syndicats étudiants ont eu gain de
cause l'obligation du temps sfax finale
a été suspendu pour la majorité des
facultés
[Musique]
à la barre face à l'arrivée du barrio au
micro dans le pays les centres de
vaccination sont mobilisés pour inoculer
la 3e 12 donc on est à presque 1 million
pour la troisième dose ce qui est bien
donc les personnes qui ont terminé leur
schéma vaccinal de doses ces on a
dépassé les 6 millions un chiffre encore
trop bas sur une population qui compte
12 millions d'habitants les autorités se
préparent déjà un nouvel afflux vers les
hôpitaux selon le directeur de
l'institut pasteur la majorité des
malades du virus hospitalisé en soins
intensifs ne sont pas vaccinés
ont fait le point à présent sur les
matches du jour pour la coupe d'afrique
des nations décevante c'est ce qu'on
peut dire des fennecs l'équipe
algérienne tenant du titre n'est pas
parvenu à battre la sierra leone nous
retrouvons tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial à yaoundé benoît perreault chez
benoît bonsoir la rencontre s'est soldée
par un match nul l'algérie a été tenu en
échec
n'est jamais facile de démarrer une
compétition lorsque vous êtes le tenant
du titre vous êtes observé attendues à
peu près partout le monde tout le monde
veut vous battre et les algériens ont
encore pu le constater aujourd'hui
incapable de venir à bout à bout d'une
valeureuse équipe de sierra leone classé
à la 108e position à la fifa on
attendait beaucoup plus des champions
d'afrique en titre face à une équipe qui
dispute seulement sa troisième coupe
d'afrique des nations après une pro et
re mi-temps très médiocre c'est vrai que
les partenaires de riyad mahrez sont
revenus en deuxième mi-temps avec
d'autres intentions mais ils ont à
chaque fois buté sur un mort un homme
mohamed camara 19 tirs dont 8 cadrés
tous repoussés par l'héroïque gardien de
la sierra leone qui a été logiquement
vous le comprendrez élu homme de cette
rencontre alors oui il y a un côté
positif à cette rencontre les algériens
n'ont pas été battus et ils se
rapprochent du coup du record
d'invincibilité toujours détenu par
l'italie désormais 35 matches que les
hommes de djamel belmadi non plus par du
mais pas sûr que ça rassure et que ce
soit un motif de satisfaction pour le
sélectionneur algérien des fennecs qui
n'auront pas le droit à l'erreur lors de
la prochaine journée ce sera face à la
guinée équatoriale avant la finale
annoncée de ce groupe e la semaine
prochaine face à la côte d'ivoire et on
suivra tout ça avec vous benoît
perreault chez merci beaucoup pour ce
décryptage
et on pourrait dire la même chose des
pharaons qui se sont inclinés face aux
eagles eagles lng le nigeria qui a battu
l'egypte 1 but à 0 but inscrit à la 30e
minute de jeu parquet leschi les aléas
nash ont écouté ses supporters à abuja
au micro de notre correspondant moïse
gomis
veut demander qu'ils allaient pouvoir
défendre sur le salat aujourd'hui elle
franchement nos joueurs ont fait un
travail fantastique
on n'a pas vu ça là du match
ils ont joué au delà de nos espérances
étant donné le récent changement de
sélectionneur je me demandais comment
notre entraîneur allez pouvoir avoir un
impact ils ont bien joué
nous avons des grands joueurs aucune
équipe dans cette can ne peut rivaliser
avec le calibre de nos joueurs
nous allons gagner la can cette année
par la grâce de dieu c'est notre tour le
nigeria
tellement avec notre mauvaise situation
économique
ça nous aurait tellement du bien
et puis dernier match du jour soudan
guinée-bissau il s'est soldé par un
match nul 0 à 0 n'oubliez pas que vous
pourrez retrouver tous les résultats et
les commentaires à 23h15 avec elliot
samuel aux manettes du journal des
sports et nos équipes sur le terrain
voilà c'est la fin de journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]